so say for example we have y equals
square root of x minus 2 so this is the
graph here we want to find the inverse
of this graph so the first thing we do
before we want to we find the inverse is
let's just go ahead and state the domain
in the range for this graph so the
domain is what the x-values can be right
so in this case the domain is going to
be X is greater than or equal to 2 in
the range which are the Y values okay
the vertical component here is going to
be Y is greater than or equal to 0 now
when you find the inverse okay of an
equation you switch the X and the y
values and you solve for the new Y but
what happens in terms of the domain and
the range is that the domain and the
range also interchanged because the
domain is associated with the ax the
range is associated with the Y so when
you switch the X and the y the domain
and the range are also switching so the
domain and the range for the new
function ok the domain is now going to
be instead of the range here that
becomes the domain X is greater than or
equal to 0 and then the range would be Y
is greater than or equal to 2 okay so
let's go ahead and pay attention to this
when we go to find the inverse so we're
going to switch the X and the y so now
we have x equals the square root of Y
minus 2 I want to solve for this Y right
here so I'm going to square both sides
so I get x squared equals y minus 2 and
I'm going to add 2 to the other side so
that's x squared plus 2 equals y and I'm
just going to flip this over so we've
get y equals x squared plus 2 but I'm
just going to put a little comment here
I'm going to state the domain but X has
to be greater than or equal to 0 because
if i graph this entire graph here this
is a parabola span shifted up 2 so it's
going to be up too and it's going to be
like this ok so there is our parabola
but notice when you find the inverse of
a graph you're looking at the reflection
of the graph over the line y equals x
but you can see we're only interested in
this piece ok that's being reflected
over so we just want this portion right
here okay and that's the part that where
X is greater than or equal to 0 we don't
want this branch over here so I'm gonna
erase this portion that's not that's not
our inverse graph we just want that
piece right there so that's an important
way to do this finding the inverse you
switch the X and the y solve for the new
Y but then you have to keep in mind look
at the domain in the range of the
original
function switch those the domain of the
inverse function is what the range used
to be of the original function so see
how I interchange those so I hope this
helped you understand how to work with
inverse functions better subscribe to
the channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon